Fans of Hawkins, Indiana and the Upside Down
will finally get to revisit their favorite
characters when Stranger Things returns for
its much-anticipated third season on Netflix
in July 2019.
Whether you're a longtime fan or a relative
newcomer, be sure to read this before you
watch.
Most of the details about Stranger Things
3 are being kept under wraps, but we do know
a few things to expect from the new season.
For one thing, we'll get to see the kids hanging
out together in summer for the first time,
which means no more battling monsters in between
classes and instead battling monsters between
visits to the community pool and Hawkins'
brand new mall.
We don't yet know what the new threat will
be exactly, but we also don't know if the
Mind Flayer from season 2 is completely out
of the picture yet.
There are also sure to be plenty of problems
beyond the creatures from the Upside Down,
in the form of the apparently corrupt Mayor
Kline, played by Cary Elwes.
In terms of where the characters will be when
the new season starts, we know from the most
recent trailer that Dustin has just returned
from summer camp.
Several relationships from season 2 will carry
over as well, including the father-daughter
dynamic between Sheriff Hopper and Eleven
and the romantic ties between Eleven and Mike,
and Lucas and Max.
Our favorite Hawkins kids are growing up so
fast!
The first season of Stranger Things is set
in November of 1983, while the second season
picks up nearly a year later, kicking things
off in Halloween of 1984.
"Trick or treat."
"You want to go trick-or-treating?!"
That kind of jump through time allows the
show to play with different pop culture references
and developments with each new season, but
it's also a necessity for a series that stars
rapidly aging young actors.
With that in mind, season 3 will time jump
yet again by nearly a year, anchoring its
story in the summer of 1985, almost two full
years after the beginning of the series.
The core cast of adventurous kids, telekinetic
powerhouses, and increasingly concerned adults
will be returning for Season 3, but the next
arc of Stranger Things is also set to introduce
several new pieces of the show's ensemble
cast.
We might not know all the surprises, but here's
who to watch for.
An icon of 1980s cinema will join the show
this year, as Cary Elwes, of Princess Bride
fame, steps up to play Mayor Kline, an image-conscious
politician who's more concerned with advancing
his career than dealing with horrifying monsters
from an alternate dimension attacking his
constituents.
Jake Busey will also join the show as a new
major player in the Hawkins community, playing
a shady, snarky reporter named Bruce
In terms of new young actors joining the series,
we have two big names to add there as well,
the first being Maya Hawke, the daughter of
Ethan Hawke and Uma Thurman.
Hawke will play new series regular Robin,
who works with Steve at Starcourt Mall and
whose life is changed when she discovers a
dark secret.
"How many children are you friends with?"
Francesca Reale, who stars in Netflix's Haters
Back Off has also joined the series in a recurring
role as Heather, a lifeguard at the local
pool.
Given what's happened in swimming pools in
the series before, we have to ask: could Heather
be the new Barb?
Perhaps the biggest mystery we've yet to learn
much about in Stranger Things 3 is exactly
who or what the Big Bad will be this time
around.
Season 1 introduced us to the horrors of the
lab that created Eleven, and ultimately gave
us access to the Upside Down and its signature
monster, the Demogorgon.
Season 2 gave us the Demo-dogs on its way
to revealing the terrifying power and size
of the Mind Flayer.
As we've already discussed, that final shot
of season 2 seems to suggest the Mind Flayer
is not entirely done with Hawkins yet, but
that doesn't mean it will be back right away.
In the Season 3 trailer, we get a look at
two entirely new threats that we can definitely
say look like enemies.
In addition to a rather unpleasant-looking
man armed with a silenced pistol, wandering
through a hall of mirrors, there's that hideous,
asymmetrical new monster roaring in a hallway.
It certainly looks like another resident of
the Upside Down has broken free to terrorize
Hawkins, but what exactly is it, and how is
it different from what we've seen before?
The kids always name their terrifying foes,
so what will they call this one?
All of the Stranger Things monsters so far
have taken their names from monsters found
in Dungeons & Dragons, and this new guy sure
doesn't look like a Gelatinous Cube.
"Gelatinous Cube eats village.
I think it's terrific."
Stranger Things is a show very much steeped
in the atmosphere of what it was like to be
a kid in the 1980s, so it was bound to get
around to mall culture eventually.
In season 3, that time has come at last.
As the show revealed in teasers last year,
1985 is the year Hawkins, Indiana finally
gets a shopping center.
The Starcourt Mall is the newest local attraction,
drawing kids and adults alike to hang out
in the food court or visit the Waldenbooks
and Sam Goody.
Steve works there, and the trailer also hints
that many Hawkins residents aren't too happy
with Mayor Kline for bringing the mall to
town in the first place.
Apart from the mall, since summer's in full
bloom we'll also get a look at the Hawkins
community pool, where the trailer reveals
Billy is working alongside the brand-new Heather
as a lifeguard.
Then there's the Hawkins Post, the town newspaper
where new character Bruce works and where
Nancy and Jonathan might end up for one reason
or another.
Because Stranger Things is a famously secretive
series, any information we can get about the
new season at all is valuable, and that includes
things that arrive out of context.
That's why it was so exciting for fans earlier
this year when Netflix dropped a brief teaser
which revealed all eight episode titles for
the third season.
"The Case of the Missing Lifeguard" doesn't
bode well for Heather and Billy, and "The
Bite" certainly seems ominous, but the big
one is the season finale: "The Battle of Starcourt."
It seems like the brand new mall might not
survive the season, for reasons that have
nothing to do with declining sales.
Stranger Things is a show which proudly and
earnestly wears its influences on its sleeve,
in part because of the blend of genre stories
that inspired it, and in part because it's
the story of a group of kids who are, at heart,
huge nerds.
These kids live and breathe the pop culture
which surrounds them, which is how we get
the main characters dressed up like Ghostbusters,
scenes of the kids digging through the D&D
Monster Manual to put names to their monstrous
enemies, and all the comic book references
that Dustin and Lucas share.
"Do you think Eleven was born with powers like an X-Man or
acquired them like Green
Lantern?"
Since the third season is set in 1985, we
can expect certain influences to play out
in real time, including the box office success
of Back to the Future and The Goonies, an
adventure that's almost tame by Stranger Things
standards.
Those are are far from the only films we should
look to as an inspiration for the new season,
though, as creators Matt and Ross Duffer teased
John Carpenter's The Thing as one major inspiration.
Meanwhile, on the other end of the scale,
star David Harbour has mentioned that the
new season will also take a few cues from
the Chevy Chase private eye comedy Fletch.
That's a pretty big shift in tone, but Stranger
Things has shown in the past that it can pull
off some pretty great comedy along with the
scares.
Between the Demogorgon and the Mind Flayer,
we've already seen plenty of disgusting monsters
invading from the Upside Down in the past
two seasons.
This time, though, we should probably expect
it to get a little more nasty.
According to co-creator Ross Duffer,
"While it's our most fun season, it also turns
out to be our grossest season."
"I know, I know, it doesn't look like much.
A little gross even.
But consider this…"
With the creators drawing inspiration from
The Thing and its infamous monstrosity, and
citing the films of David Cronenberg and zombie
auteur  George Romero
as major influences, we could be in for a
whole new level of body horror.
And that's before we get into the scale of
things.
Season 2 gave us a sprawling series of tunnels
that seemed like they were infecting the entire
city, and that's not slowing down as we move
into the next season, either.
The still-mysterious new threat was even played
up by Noah Schnapp, who plays Will Byers,
when he said
"The threat is… it's brutal.
It gets bad.
It's very big... like it's taking over Hawkins."
The wait between seasons of Stranger Things
has been a long one, but that doesn't mean
the franchise has just completely shut down
in the time since we last saw the kids from
Hawkins.
In fact, the world of Stranger Things has
only expanded in the time since the last new
episode was released.
If you're really missing this world and its
characters, you can dig into some tie-in reading
right now.
"I am on a curiosity voyage ...
And I need my paddles to travel.
These books...
these books are my paddles."
In the world of prose, we now have an official
Stranger Things companion book, Worlds Turned
Upside Down, along with two tie-in novels.
Suspicious Minds tells the story of Eleven's
mother and the experiments that were done
on her, and Darkness on the Edge of Town,
flashes back to a story of Sheriff Hopper's
time as a cop in New York City in the 1970s.
In the comics world, there are also new stories
to dig into.
In the fall of 2018, Dark Horse Comics launched
a four-issue Stranger Things miniseries that
tells the story of what happened to Will Byers
during the time he was stuck in the Upside
Down.
The company has also announced Stranger Things:
Six, another new miniseries set to tell the
story of a different girl experimented on
at the Hawkins lab.
After its debut season became a pop culture
phenomenon on Netflix, It took 15 months for
Stranger Things to return for Round 2.
For some fans, that seemed like an eternity,
but that wait time has already been overtaken
by the long wait before the arrival of Season
3.
"How long is a while … A year?"
A year?
By the time we get to the new episodes, we'll
have been waiting for nearly two years.
The delay between seasons stretched on into
2018 with no real updates, until Netflix vice
president of original programming Cindy Holland
made it clear last summer that we'd be waiting
a little while, and that Netflix was fine
with that.
Holland told a very patient audience
"It's a hand-crafted show.
The Duffer brothers and Shawn Levy work really
hard and they understand the stakes are high.
They want to deliver something bigger and
better than what they did last year."
With everything we've seen so far, we're betting
season 3 will be worth the wait.
Now that the third season of Stranger Things
is finally almost upon us after a very long
wait, it's time to once again ask the question
of how much longer the show will go on.
Will we get a fourth season.
A fifth?
Do we hope for a sixth?
Will we follow Lucas, Dustin, Will, Mike,
and Eleven as they go off to college and encounter
the pop culture of the early '90s?
This is something the Duffer brothers and
executive producer Shawn Levy have addressed
before, and the answer seems to be that the
shortest run we'll get at this point is four
seasons of the show.
At one point the Duffer brothers were considering
wrapping things up with Season 4 for sure,
but now they're considering an expansion.
As Levy said,
"The truth is we're definitely going four
seasons and there's very much the possibility
of a fifth.
Beyond that, it becomes I think very unlikely."
They might not get to the '90s, or even experience
the confusion and disappointment of seeing
Ghostbusters II, but that means we still have
a while left to spend with the Hawkins gang
knowing that there's at least one more adventure
to come.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
obsessions are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.